one of the sadder things about art and
music is that it's often
inter-leaved with business folk
i suppose that's the way of the world if
you have a capitalist system but it
makes
that
business folks rubbing up against
artists um
can sometimes destroy a fragile
mind and soul like
a to me like one of the best
representations of an artist honestly
johnny i of the designer from apple
and he's just so fragile with his ideas
and he talked about like when he has
ideas
he really wouldn't show it to steve jobs
or anybody except for the small design
team because he was so nervous that it
would it would break
let's give it a chance let it give it a
chance to grow
and it seems like the outside world
uh business people pr people people kind
of uh have not lost themselves in the
passion of creating but instead of kind
of representing or
like making deals all that kind of stuff
they they can kind of trample on those
little ideas
and it's
it's sad to see
yeah it's really it's really
heartbreaking to see because you know
how much trampling there's going on
it's one of the main jobs my jobs as a
record producer is to
um
keep the
keep the voices
away from the artist from all the people
who are really on their side but don't
know you know like the uh whether it be
people um
anyone on the business side who doesn't
make things
they're excited to do their part you
know they're excited if when you deliver
the thing the art that you make to me
then we can start the project
but there's nothing to
sell if the art doesn't happen in the
right way and it has to be protected and
it can't happen
on the same kind of a timetable
that
um
that business can it's just a different
thing it doesn't art doesn't come in a
quarterly way
and that doesn't apply just to music or
it applies to art it applies to all
creative pursuits like this is generally
the case again
at mit
it's just there's the administration
and then there is
the professors and students and the
professors students are the creative
folk yeah they create stuff they dream
they have wild ideas that go on tangents
and so on they they uh they have hopes
and they they go with those and they get
like on these weird passionate pursuits
and then administration can often just
trample on that
um
and
they they set up bars on
all kinds of in all kinds of ways that
you think you're not actually hurting
um
but you really are
and
you know i won't mention why but because
this happens to everybody and i have a
large amount of leverage at mit now but
even i get a little bit of pressure
in such stupid ways to like
don't like
be careful
be careful less like we really want your
career to succeed be careful and that
little pressure to an artist you know do
you want to go a cappella do you want to
go do you want to go do a country record
like be careful like you're already a
superstar be careful yeah and in that
way you kind of push people
like flock of fish into
one fish tank where they're all the same
yeah and it's it's sad to see and it's
obviously in the modern world there's
nice mechanism to protect
to let artists flourish a little bit
more because they get to put themselves
to the world and get a little bit more
confidence maybe different funding
mechanisms all that kind of stuff but
tremendous problem that the
the voices that don't understand
interfering with the process is huge the
other side of it is in success
there can be a lack of reality where
all of the people around the successful
person just tell them everything they do
is great
and then they they don't have anything
to bump up against anymore have a
realistic
uh sense of what's
what how things work or how how it how
the
how things measure you know
um
so both sides are really important both
both
avoiding the voices getting in the way
and having a trusted
group of you know a sangha a group of
people who
can say you know i don't know if that's
as good and you can still you know say i
don't care what you think that's fine
but it helps to hear it you know it
helps to have
if someone who
you respect
tells you something isn't good enough
it's helpful when you know it comes from
a place of love when it comes from a
place of wisdom 100 and not from a place
of fear not from a place of oh this
doesn't sound like it's going to do as
well as your last thing that's yeah
that's not the point the point is on
this uh
quest for greatness
are you
living up to your
ability
you